run  fueled by their defense brian  bridges  tough shooting night continues  for bridges james with another rebound  lebron's got five boards now  here's carmelo anthony a little side  dribble  [Applause]  and now anthony's going to get a t  he thought he was fouled he is really  upset  and the third technical of the night  oh yeah right to the midsection  right as he was going up he flew by jay  crowder flew by  but came back with his left  [Applause]  and just kind of flailed  at the midsection  carmelo anthony's out second tee of the  night  two teas from anthony westbrook got one  earlier in this game as well and ryan  that's that's a win if you're monty  williams in the sense because  mello has been so consistent at being  able to shoot the basketball for this  lakers team  now you take that threat off the floor  here  let's see if trevor ariza can continue  his  solid first half with  11 points off the bench  rosedale going to the book here